dans quelques jours un petit être
étranger plutôt laid va atterrir en
france dans les salles de cinéma
it is et son nom à l'américaine e t
comme extra terrestre c'est la dernière
créature née du talent du réalisateur
américain steven spielberg de son talent
et de beaucoup d'argent
le budget du film était de 7 milliards
de centimes pour spielberg ce n'est pas
un gros budget le film a déjà rapporté à
son producteur plus de 7 200 milliards
de centimes
et il n'est projeté jusqu'ici qu'aux
états unis où il nourrit un véritable
phénomène de société
il faut dire que ici c'est aussi et
surtout une très belle histoire d'amour
france roche et à la cances l'homme qui
tourne à jaws les aventuriers de l'arche
perdue rencontre du troisième clip
steven spielberg frappe encore c'est une
minuscule épopée
avec iti ce réalisateur de 34 ans est
pour la quatrième fois de sa carrière en
tête des recettes américaines et le
premier défendre son extraterrestre en
or massif atterrira à paris en fanfare
et avec une belle estampille officielle
car spielberg est allé consulter les
experts de la nasa qui se pensent à
longueur d'année sur le problème des
créatures de la galaxie son héros est
une bête pas vraiment gracieuse en forme
de bobines unis deux pattes palmées deux
doigts de sorcière perdu sur terre est
menacée par les adultes
il est recueilli et sauvé par un petit
garçon adorable bien entendu gilbert
guay a inventé le conte de fées
post-atomique ity c'est le petit
chaperon rouge de l'espace au pays des
grands méchants hommes
jack tchador opposé le cosmos à la vie
j'aime tout ce qui est contraire à nos
habitudes
c'est un film qui est vraiment sorti
deux mois qui vient plus de mon coeur
que tous mes autres films pas gâteux oui
j'ai voulu quitter ma planète secourir a
mené une créature de l'espace il à faire
réagir comme je le désire je suis un peu
plus tôt repeindre il n'y a pas de mal à
vieillir tout en restant éternellement
je vois vous allez bien vu qui est sauvé
grâce à une bicyclette volante 60
millions de spectateurs en six mois déjà
200 milliards de centimes de recettes
hilti s'annonce comme le plus grand
succès de l'histoire du cinéma américain
clientèle privilégiée les enfants bien
sûr ils rêvent tous de rencontrer ici
pour pouvoir l'aider à rentrer chez lui
certains habitants ont déjà vu le film
jusqu'à huit fois avec la proche des
fêtes de noël avec cette passion des
enfants pour hiti le petit monstre
sympathique envahi d'amérique
il est parti d'abord dans les arcades là
où on va jouer aux jeux électroniques
une
les joueurs et titi a fabriqué son
téléphone cosmique qui lui permettra de
téléphoner chez lui et leur entrée dans
la maison
le modèle de jeux pour ordinateurs
familiaux ce qu'on utilise chez soif et
des jambes
hilti est aussi présent en disque en
livre enjeu de société auto des jeux de
cartes sur les draps de lit ou les
t-shirts et bien sûr en poupe et toutes
tailles tous modèles on le retrouve même
sur des paquets de chewing gum un énorme
marché de plusieurs centaines de
millions de dollars et déjà une cascade
de procès car il ya les vrais haïti ce
cas autorisés le producteur steven
spielberg et les fours les imitations
très nombreuses et pas forcément moins
cher
mais les vrais copains dit-il les
enfants eux se moquent bien de ces
questions d'argent
un nouveau personnage désormais entrer
dans leur monde imaginaire et dans leurs
rêves aux côtés de snoopy de peanuts ou
de mickey
et le monde de l'enfance apprend à faire
connaissance avec le nouveau venu